ก็
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียม
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนวันนี้ค่ะนักเรียน
วันนี้ผู้เรียนวันนี้วันอ่ะวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
ค่ะ
อย่าทำให้ใหญ่ขึ้น
วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะ
ตีผชอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
ปีคศอะไรคะ
คศ
ต2013 22 ค่ะเหมือน
กับตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 น
9 นาทีค่ะ
ค่ะก็เป็นตอนบ่ายๆแล้วนะคะครูผู้หญิงกับ
ครูเรียมนี้คิดว่าตื่นแล้วตื่นร้อย
เปอร์เซ็นต์
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงนอนกี่โมงคะ
ผู้หญิงนอนประมาณ 23:00 น
ประมาณ 10:00 นฮ่าๆ 19:00 นคู่เรียมเหรอ
คะทุเรียนนอนกี่โมงเมื่อคืนนี้เรียนนอน
ประมาณที่ 1
แล้ววันนี้ครูเรียมตื่นกี่โมงคะวัน
ให้ตื่นหกโมงเช้าค่ะ
6:00 นคูเรียนก็นอนประมาณตื่นตี 2 ตี 3
ตี 4 ตี 5  6 ห้าชั่วหมูมุง
ใช่หรอ
ก็โอเคนะคะเมื่อเช้านี้ตื่นขึ้นมาก็รู้
สึกง่วง
นิดหน่อยก็เลยเอาอ๋อ
ดื่มกาแฟค่ะผู้หญิงเอาเงินแล้ว
เคลรี่เรียมเนี่ยดื่มกาแฟทุกวันไหมคะ
เตรียมไม่ได้ดื่มกาแฟทุกวันนะคะผู้หญิง
วันไหนที่ง่วงๆก็ดื่มกาแฟ
อ่า
ไม่เหมือนครูหญิงนะถ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้
ดื่มกาแฟหนึ่งวันรู้สึกไม่โอเคปวดหัว
หงุดหงิดแบบแต่
แม่ไม่ได้อ้ะผู้หญิงต้องดื่มกาแฟทุกวัน
หนู
แบบนี้เรียกว่าครูหญิงติดกาแฟได้ไหมคะ
เนี่ย
ไม่จะได้นะครูหญิงเนี่ยติดกาแฟถ้าวันไหน
นะส่วนนอนแล้วก็ตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วก็แบบอาจจะ
ลืมทำวีดีโอนู่นนี่นั่นแล้วก็รู้สึกแบบ
ทำไมเงินมันไม่โอเค
ไม่ได้ทำอะไรก็ยังไม่ได้ดื่มกาแฟจะเป็นคน
ที่ติดกาแฟงู
แท็กครูเรียมแหละไม่ได้ติดกาแฟ
ไม่ค่ะไม่ได้ติดกาแฟแต่อาจจะเป็นติดอย่าง
อื่นนะคะผู้หญิงหรอทุเรียนติดอะไรคะ
น่ากลัวหรอกเราคนเลี้ยงพูดอ่านตัวอย่าง
อื่นได้ป่ะ
อ๋อฤดูรู้หรือ
ผู้หญิงกันจะบอกว่าดูจากครูเรียมแล้ว
เนี่ยน่าจะไม่ได้ติดของกิน
ไม่ได้ติดของกินผู้หญิงเรียนต้องมี
หนังสืออยู่รอบๆตัว
หนึ่งจะรู้สึกแบบนี้ติดหายใจหนังสือใช่
ไหมคะใช่
ทำไมอ่ะถ้าครูเรียมเนี่ยไปข้างนอกนะ
คูเรียมเนี่ยจากบ้านแล้วก็ไปร้านกาแฟ EP
คอมพิวเตอร์ไปทำงานคุณเรียนต้องเอา
หนังสือติดไปด้วยเหรอคะใช่ค่ะเตรียมก็เอา
หนังสือติดแล้วด้วย
ถ้าไม่มีถ้าครูเรียมไม่ได้เอาหนังสือไป
โอเคไหมคะไม่โอเคค่ะและเตรียมจะรู้สึกว่า
ไม่มีอะไรทำไม่มีอะไรทำ
ใช่เพราะว่าเวลาที่ไหนว่างๆไม่ได้ทำงาน
เตรียมก็ชอบอ่านหนังสือเนื้อหรือ
แต่บางทีไปร้านกาแฟทำงานทำงานมากๆก็เอา
หนังสือไปด้วยนะคะแต่ว่าไม่ได้อาจก็มีแต่
ลืมสบายใจ
จะไม่ใช่ถ้าอย่างนั้นก็ครูเรียมก็น่าจะ
ติดหนังสือแล้วหาแต่งผู้หญิงไม่ติด
หนังสือนภูเรียม
ผู้หญิงติดอะไรติดโทรศัพท์
โทรศัพท์
ไม่บางคนเนี่ยเขาติดโทรศัพท์ก็คือถ้าออก
จากบ้านแล้วก็ลืมมาถ้าในกระเป๋าเนี่ยไม่
มีโทรศัพท์เนี่ยไม่ได้ต้องกลับบ้านแล้วก็
มาเอาโทรศัพท์ติดโทรศัพท์เนื้อ
คู่เรียนติดใบอ่ะ
เตรียมไม่ติดโทรศัพท์นะคะวันไหนที่แบบนี้
ลืมเอาโทรศัพท์ใส่ในกระเป๋า
เอาไว้ที่บ้าน
เอาไว้ที่บ้านออกไปข้างนอกแล้วก็
ดีจังดีๆไม่มีใครโทรมาหา
ก็อาจผู้หญิงอาจ
แปลว่าโรงเรียมไม่ได้ติดโทรศัพท์สวยไม่
ได้ติดโทรศัพท์ไม่ข้างนึงแต่เพราะว่าแบบ
อย่าง
คุยเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนนะคิดว่าตัวเองปิด
โทรศัพท์ว่าอยู่บ้านเนี่ยบทจะเล่น
โทรศัพท์บ่อยๆแบบเวลาทำนั่งอยู่อ่ะแล้วก็
แบบไม่รู้จะทำอะไรก็จะหยิบโทรศัพท์ขึ้นมา
แล้วก็เล่นเล่นอ้าแต่มีอีก 1 วันเนี่ย
เมื่อก่อนอ่ะไปทำงานแล้วก็ลืมโทรศัพท์ไว้
ที่บ้านคุณก็ไม่เป็นไร
โอเคไม่มีโทรศัพท์โอเคก็เลย
อย่าคิดว่าแบบนั้นอาจจะไม่ได้เรียกว่าติด
โทรศัพท์
น่าจะไม่ได้ติดโทรศัพท์
สายค่ะก็ไม่ได้คิดคนที่บางคนที่ติด
โทรศัพท์จริงๆที่ไม่มีโทรศัพท์
เพราะว่าบางคนอาจจะติดเกมในโทรศัพท์ไงมี
โทรศัพท์แล้วก็เล่นเกมใช่ไหมคะเล่นเกมใน
โทรศัพท์ก็อาจจะไม่ได้ติดโทรศัพท์ที่แบบ
ว่าต้องเล่นโซเชียลมีเดียเล่น Facebook
เล่น Twitter แต่ว่าเล่นเกมในโทรศัพท์
ก็เลยติดโทรศัพท์คู่ถ้าคุณยำเก๋คะ
เล่นเกมนิดหน่อยค่ะคู่หญิงน้อยมากงั้นครู
เรียมก็ไม่สนติดเกมไม่จำเมื่อก่อนครูหญิง
เคยติดเกมนะ
แบบ
ผู้หญิงติดเกมอะไรแขก
มันเป็นเกมชื่อฟิตด้อม
แล้วก็เธอคุณเรียวมันจะไม่รู้จักฟิตแต่
ผู้หญิงไม่มีแล้วไงตอนนี้คุยไม่เล่นแล้ว
เมื่อก่อนติดมากก็คือคิดอยากกลับบ้านอยาก
กลับบ้านฝากสิ่งทานก็พื่นนอนเล่นเกม
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยก็จะชาร์จชาร์จที่นี่แล้วก็
นอนแล้วก็เล่นเกมเล่นเกม 1 ชั่วโมง 2
ชั่วโมง 3 ชั่วโมงจำนวน 10 มากๆเล่นทุก
วัน
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ไม่ไปทำงานตื่นนอนมาก็
เล่นเกมก็แบบคือเล่นเกมส์แล้วเกมมันมี is
ซื้อซื้อของก็จ่ายเงินจ่ายเงินซื้อของกับ
1 เดือนคิดว่าอันนี้ไม่เยอะนะคะคนที่เขา
ติดเกมอ่ะเราจะจ่ายเงินเยอะมากๆแต่ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยน่าจะเดือนละประมาณ 2  3,000
สอบพาน
3,000 บาทเกมหูสำหรับผู้หญิงหรือแบบโห
เยอะให้สำหรับแล้วก็หมูเยอะ
ตอนหลังพันจ่ายไปกับการเล่นเกม
ๆค่ะ
ติดเกมพอเล่นเกมมากๆติดมากๆเลยเหรอปวดบ่า
ไม่โอเคก็เลยแบบเลิกนะตอนนี้เนี่ยเต็มที่
ติดเกมแล้วแถวเมื่อก่อนติดเกม
แต่คู่เรียนน่ะดีแล้วค่ะไม่ติดเกมผู้หญิง
ทำให้เรียมนึกถึงเมื่อก่อน
ที่อายุประมาณ 10 เท่าไหร่อ่ะ 12 หรือ
เปล่า 12  13 กับฟิล์มก็เล่นเกมนะคะเล่น
เกมคอมพิวเตอร์
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงอยู่แต่เก็บไว้เกมเดอะซิมไหม
รู้จักค่ะรู้จักเคยได้ยินจำ The  Sims
ใช่เตรียมเล่นประมาณวันละวันละประมาณ 8
ชั่วโมง
เห้ยเขาติดนะ
ให้เรารู้สึกว่าปวดตามาก
ปวดป้า
แล้วก็โดนป้าป้าว่าทุกวันอ่ะเล่นเกมทำไม
มันนานมัน 8 ชั่วโมงวันนั้น 9 ชั่วโมงจะ
ยืมเท่าไหร่ครับขี้เกียจฟังไม่ฝากไว้ฝาก
เลยอ่ะไม่เล่นตอนนี้ก็เลยนี่ค่ะคุยแต่มัน
จะ
เอาก็โหเล่นวันละ 8 ชั่วโมงก็น่าจะติดนะ
น่าจะติดเกมแล้วคะแต่ว่า
แก๊งผู้หญิงเหมือนไม่ลาเราโตขึ้นโตขึ้น
น้องเราก็อาจจะแบบเลิกติดไปแล้วไม่ติด
แล้วหรือหรือว่าเราไปติดอย่างอื่นหรือ
เปล่าคะมัน
ไม่หาเราก็ไปติดอย่างอื่น
ความใหญ่
อย่างรู้หญิงใช่ไหมถ้าเราจะติดนั้นก็อาจ
ติดกาแฟนะคะก็จะติดนะเพราะว่าต้องดื่มนะ
ถ้าไม่ดื่มเนี่ยไม่ได้แล้วก็ขออันนี้เขา
ก็ไม่รู้ว่าเรียกติดไหมอ่ะแต่เวลาที่เกาะ
นร้อนเมื่อก่อนก็ไม่เป็นเป็นหนึ่งนะคะผู้
หญิงไม่เป็นเมื่อก่อนก็คือแบบคือเป็นคน
นอนง่ายก็คือก็โง่ง่วงนอนแล้วก็หลับแต่
เหมือนตอนนี้เราเราอายุมากขึ้นหรอเราก็
เลยนอนน้อยลง
แต่ว่าตอนเนี้ยทุกคืนทุกคืนทุกคืนก่อนนอน
ผู้หญิงก็จะเปิดเหมือนๆ port  Cash นะมัน
ไม่ได้เป็นพอดแคสต์นะคะมันอยู่ใน YouTube
เป็นเป็นแซวจิกเค้าน่าจะคล้ายๆกับครู
เรียมก็คือชอบอ่านหนังสือแล้วก็จะอ่าน
หนังสือแล้วก็จะเอามาเล่าเล่าแอร์เอเชีย
แนว YouTube เหมือนแบบเล่าเรื่อง Charlie
and  Chocolate ระยะหน้านี้เนี่ย Harry
Potter  Years  5 ผู้หญิงก็จะเปิดทุกคืน
เกือบเปิด YouTube แล้วก็เขาก็จะเล่า
ประมาณแบบอีก 3 นาทีจะคุยกับหลับแล้วแต่
ถ้าไม่เปิดนะดูยูทูปอย่างอื่นไม่หลับแต่
ถ้าเปิด YouTube ที่เขาเล่าเป็นแบบ
หนังสืออ่ะอ่านหนังสือสมมตคุณอ่านหนังสือ
ใช่มั้ยอะไรเมอร์เดอร์อะไรสักอย่างเนี่ย
อ่านเสร็จแล้วก็มาเล่าอ่อนหนังสือมีใคร
บ้างแล้วก็เล่าคุณก็จะเปิดแล้วก็นอนฝั่ง
ก็หลับต้องเปิดทุกคือน่าจะติดไว้
แล้วจะติดแล้วนะคะผู้หญิง
น้องเหมือนเด็กๆเหมือนเด็กๆเวลาจะนอนคุณ
พ่อคุณแม่เล่านิทานแล้วเด็กๆก็หลับ
ใส่ผู้หญิงเนี่ยฟังใน YouTube
แล้วก็หลับ
คูเรียร์มีไหมคะติดอะไรก่อนนอนไหมเวลา
ก่อนที่จะก็ต้องทำเอา
ลืมชอบกินบางคนชอบที่ 5 ผู้หญิง
แล้วยังไม่รู้นะไม่รู้ว่าตัวเองติดกินกิน
อะไรสักอย่างก่อนนอนมีวันนึงของไปนอนโรง
แรมที่ต้องมีอีกคนนึงนอนอยู่ข้างๆมี
เพื่อนอ่ะเด็กในห้องเดียวกันเราก็อยู่
ด้วยกันหลายวันที่นี่เขาบอกเลี้ยงทำอะไร
เดี๋ยวกำลังแกะช็อกโกแลต
แล้วก็กินกินๆก่อนที่จะนอนแล้วเขาบอกว่า
เขาเห็นเลียมทำแบบนี้ทุกๆคืนก่อนนอน
ๆๆๆอะไรสักอย่างคือทุเรียนเนี่ยอาบน้ำ
เสร็จแล้วใช่ไหมล้างหน้าแปรงฟันใส่ชุดนอน
กำลังจะนอนแล้วก็ต้องหยิบช็อกโกแลตมากิน
แหละแน่นอนได้
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนั้นซึ่งเพื่อนบอกนะคะ
เพื่อนบอกเลยเพิ่นจริงด้วย
ทำไมแบบเยี่ยมชอบปวดฟันปวดฟันรอบหมด
รู้แต่ว่าเป็นเพราะเรียมติดกินขนมก่อนนอน
แล้วไม่รู้ว่าตัวเองติด
ต้องมาแบบครูเรียนก็จะอาบน้ำแปรงฟันเสร็จ
แล้วให้แล้วก็กินขนมแล้วเราจะหลับเลยไง
เราก็ไม่ลุกขึ้นไปไปแปลงฟันอีก 1 ครั้ง
แล้วทำแบบนี้แบบ automatic มานานมาก
ก็น่าจะติดน่ะใช่เหมือนเด็กๆอีกแล้วนะ
สวัสดีค่ะ
เป็นเราเป็นเด็กๆบางคนเขาก็จะติดแบบดูด
นิ้วสมัยเวลาจะนอนนะเวลาเขาจะนอนแล้วเด็ก
ๆอ่ะค่ะเขาก็จะเอานิ้วโป่งแม่เด็กบางคน
เราก็จะดูดนิ้วแล้วก็หลับหน่อยติดดูดนิ้ว
จนผู้หญิงเคยแบบเมื่อก่อนทำงานนะคะแล้วก็
มีรูปคู่ของครูพี่เขาเป็นเด็กอ่ะเขาติด
ดูดนิ้วต้นอายุ
คลื่นขวบหรือ 6 ขวบ
ตาลมากและจนฟันใช่มั้ยเวลาดูดนิ้วมากๆ
เนี่ยฟันฟันมันจะเหยินอ่อนมา
ตายค่ะตั้งแต่เด็กอะดูดจนนิ้วอ่ะคือถ้า
เขาจะนอนน่ะเขาต้องดูดนิ้ว
เหมือนเด็กไทยไม่ค่อยไหมอะนั้นเขาเป็นลูก
ครึ่งนะคะลูกครึ่งไทยแล้วก็ฝรั่งอยากคุย
อิงตอนเด็กๆก็ไม่ติดดูด
ไม่มีหนึ่งก็ไม่มีผู้เรียนตอนเด็กๆติด
อะไรไหมไม่มีหรอกอ่ะถ้าไม่มีราคาเพราะว่า
ถ้าเกิดเราดูดนิ้วเมื่อไหร่นะผู้ใหญ่ก็จะ
บอกเอามือออกอำเภอเองตลอดเวลาใช่
สิเรา
เราก็จะไม่ให้เราดูดนิ้วๆทรายแต่ว่าเมื่อ
เมื่อก่อนตอนเด็กๆอ่ะอันนี้มันก่อนนอนนะ
แต่มันคล้ายๆเป็นสิ่งที่เราทำ
automatic เหมือนครูเรียมแล้วก็มีคนบอก
เราเราก็เลยรู้ว่าออเราติดคือเมื่อก่อน
น่ะครูหญิงชอบติดแบบมันจะมีสองอย่างก็คือ
1 ชอบติดแบบท่านนั่งเฉยๆอย่างเงี้ยอะ
นั่งเรียนเรียนหนังสืออยู่เงี้ยครูก็พูด
ปิดก็จะนั่งแล้วก็ทำอะไรติดม้วนอันนี้อัน
นี้ใส่โคโลนีคนบ้าหรือเปล่าเนี่ยม้วนผม
ก็เดี๋ยวกันแน่นม้วนผมผมปืนๆว่ะหญิงโอเค
ไหมอ่ะที่ม้วนผม
เพิ่งก็อีกอย่างหนึ่งก็คือชอบเขาเรียก
อะไรอ่ะเหมือนเราชอบเอาฟันน่ะเราก็กัดปาก
อะขอวันนี้หรอเขาคงคือคุณแม่ๆๆข้างในทั้ง
ในข้างในอย่างเงี้ยแบบเวลาเรานั่งไม่ใช่
กัดป่าวเนี่ย
ก็เหมือนจะนั่งเหรอกัดปากของเรา
ก็โทษเวลาโดดแต่เรารู้ตัวนะทำปกติจนแบบ
เราทำไปกินข้าวมั้งเรากับผู้ใหญ่นอนกับ
คุณน้าอย่างเงี้ยเขาก็บอกว่าเฮ้ยทำไมหญิง
ทำแบบนี้กับทำไมนั่งแล้วก็กลับปากแบบมัน
ดูไม่โอเค
ไม่รู้ว่าแบบเราติดอ่ะแต่ตอนนี้ไม่แล้วนะ
ครับเหมือนครูเรียมแล้วนะฮะไม่ติดแล้วโต
แล้วออกกำลังนึกภาพผู้หญิงที่กำลังม้วนผม
แล้วก็รถห่วย
เหมือนคนบ้ามากแล้วกับ
คนนี้โอเคไหมอ่ะต้องไปโรงพยาบาล
ก่อนเพื่อนผู้หญิงก็เลยถามว่าโอเคไหมโอเค
ไหมกูเรียกว่ากูดูดนักเรียนลองดูว่าแล้ว
สมมุติผู้หญิงนั่งแล้วอ้ะ
มันก็จะคิดผู้หญิงนี่โอเคหรือเปล่า
[เพลง]
แต่ตอนนี้ไม่ทำแล้วมาหานักเรียนไม่ทำให้
ทำเอามาทำงานเนี่ยเราต้องอยู่ข้างหน้าใช่
ไหมมีนักเรียนเนี่ยดูเราครูเรียมพูดแล้ว
ก็คุยก็ใช่ค่ะกูเนี้ยมนักเลยพวกผู้หญิงทำ
อะไรได้อะลืมคิดว่านักเรียนสนใจนะเขาว่า
นักเรียนอาจจะมีติดอะไรบางอย่างเหมือนกัน
อุ้ยคูเรียมเมื่อก่อน
นักเรียนมีนักเรียนที่เขาเรียนหนังสืออ่ะ
แล้วแบบเวลาที่เขาเครียดอ่ะเขามันฟังภาษา
ไทยไม่เข้าใจอ่ะแล้วเราไม่เคยเห็นมีคนไทย
ทำนะไม่ใช่ไม่เคยเห็นเหมือนเรานะเราผู้
หญิงไม่เคยเห็นก็คือบางคนเขาจะติดเหมือน
กับกัดเล็บอ่ะนั่งเรียนแล้วก็
กลับเล็บเพราะว่าเขาเครียด
เหมือนแบบหรือว่ามันอาจจะไม่เครียดก็ได้
นะเขาก็นั่งฟังนั่งฟังซักประมาณ 5 นาที 10
นาทีเขาก็จะเริ่มยกมือขึ้นมาแล้ว
ก็กัดเล็บไปด้วยอ่ะแต่ว่าคิดว่าคนไทยไม่
ติดอาจจะเหมือนที่ครูเรียมบอกก็คือพอยก
มือขึ้นมาปุ๊บคุณพ่อคุณแม่ตี่นถ้าเราเอ้ย
มิติ
นักเรียนติดกัดเล็บไหมคะดูวีดีโอช่อง
คอมเพลนสิเบิ้ลไทยไปด้วยแล้วก็กลัดเลี้ยง
ไปด้วยหรือว่าม้วนผมไม่คุยหรือว่าบางคน
อาจจะแบบรู้สึกหงุดหงิดอยู่ไม่ได้ดื่ม
กาแฟเพราะว่าติดกาแฟ
ที่เราจะคุยเนี่ยตีเงินติดบ้านนะคะติด
บ้านอีกไม่ชอบไปข้างนอกงานอยู่บ้าน
ถ้าอย่างนั้นเรียนก็คงเป็นแบบตรงข้ามตรง
ข้ามกับผู้หญิงก็คือติดเที่ยวติดเที่ยว
ออกไปข้างนอกบ้านบ่อยมาก
ก็แม่จะบอกว่าเรียนมบ้านอยู่ได้นะลูก
ผู้หญิงไงออกไปข้างนอกบ้างก็ได้นะคะครู
หญิงออกไปเที่ยวไหนค่ะมีชื่อคนมีเหตุผล
พูดกับผู้หญิงแบบนี้ว่าไอ้ข้างนอกก็ได้นะ
ไม่ต้องอยู่แต่ในบ้าง
น้องแต่ว่าไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนติดอะไรบ้าง
นะคะจะได้เรียนติดอะไรก็คอมเม้นบอกเราได้
เนาะ
ใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วมั้ยทุเรียนม 1 กำลังดู
อยู่ว่าเราคุยกันตั้งแต่
บ่าย 3 โมง 9 โมงเจ้าทั้งหมดเวลาในรหัส
หมดเวลาแล้วเดี๋ยวมาเจอกับคุยหญิงแล้วก็
ครูเรียมใหม่ในวีดีโอนะๆนะคะ I ค่ะสำหรับ
วีดีโอนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนนะคะเป็นไปแล้วเนาะ
สวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนบอกว่าติดช่องคอมพรีเฮนอีเบอร์
ไทยค่ะทุเรียนมนี้ค่ะติดและดีค่ะอะ
ฮะโอเคอ่า
by  A